Незвичне поєднання - голландські краєвиди і спів українською.
Так звучить пісня "Ой на горі, та й женці жнуть"
у виконанні Хору імені Лисенка.
Усі 40 співаків цього хору – нідердандці.
Колектив  існує вже 20 років,
і його репертуар складається виключно з українських пісень.
Український оперний співак і диригент Мирослав Антонович
у 1996 році заснував хор імені Лисенка у селищі Тюль ент Вааль.
Теперішній директор і водночас соліст
сільського хору Брем Босхардт збирається на репетицію.
Українська вишиванка.
Ручної роботи, подивіться.
Кожен учасник хору має таку вдома.
У жінок вони ще красивіші.
Це кадри ювілейного виступу на 20-річчя хору Лисенка.
Хор співав літургію у кафедральному соборі Утрехта.
Щовівторка на сьому вечора з навколишніх селищ
до Тюль ент Ваалю учасники хору приїжджають на репетицію.
Ярослав Синявський – за фахом лікар,
однак як носій української
вирішив допомагати співакам з вимовою.
Всі слова пісень записані нідерландською транслітерацією.
Вимовою також займаємось,
бо є такі звуки,
які вони не дуже гарно вимовляють.
Це щ, ч,
ш, ж
- це дуже важко.
Зароблені від концертів гроші хор спрямовує
на підтримку музичної школи у рідному місті засновника хору
Мирослава Антоновича - Долині в Івано-Франківській області.
Крім того колектив фінансує стажування в Нідерландах
успішних учнів українських музичних закладів.
Хор вже кілька разів був в Україні - тож має уявлення
і про політичне життя країни.
Директор хору, який проголосував "за" на референдумі щодо Асоціації Україна-ЄС,
пояснює чому більшість голландців були "проти".
Ми голосували проти засилля у нас
низькооплачуваних водіїв вантажівок з Польщі,
ми голосували проти
нескінченного виділення Греції величезних сум
для підтримки економіки,
ми не голосували проти України.
Це був протест всередині ЄС.
Та більшість і не читала,
і не знає, що там написано в тій угоді про асоціацію.
Я проголосувала "за", бо мені подобається Україна.
Думаю, це дуже важливо, щоб
українці були разом з Європою.
Люди проголосували проти,
бо їм не роз'яснили сутність питання.
У травні Хор імені Лисенка вирушає в тур Україною.
Востаннє нідерландці були в Україні
ще до початку російської агресії.
Серед українців в них багато друзів,
тож вони з нетерпінням чекають на зустріч,
аби на власному досвіді переконатися,
чим зараз живе країна, культуру якої вони популяризують в Європі.